Kanye West has been released from the  hospital the news comes after the rapper  was hospitalized at UCLA Medical Center  for what a source called a mental  breakdown the source told ET quote it  was a combination of a lot of issues  stress anxiety paranoia he just broke a  source close to the 39 year old rapper  and wife Kim kardashian-west told ET  that Kim has been by his side 24-7 that  she wouldn't leave the hospital until he  did despite initial rumors of a split a  source close to the Kardashians tells us  Kim feels more connected to Kanye than  ever just before the hospitalization  Yeezy made headlines for his erratic  behavior at his latest shows Beyonce I  was hurt can I help that you say you  would perform unless you want in your  tahir over me  you